В'ячеслав Чорновіл загинув від "чотирьох ударів кастетів",
а не в автокатастрофі. Такі заголовки облетіли українські ЗМІ
та викликали бурхливі дискусії в соцмережах.
Про те, що відомий політик загинув не внаслідок ДТП,
вже не вперше заявляє колишній заступник генпрокурора Микола Голомша.
Щоправда, раніше ці заяви не набирали такого розголосу.
Голомша вів справу Чорновола у двотисячних,
за часів президентства Віктора Ющенка, керував слідчими та прокурорами
і безпосередньо був знайомий з результатами експертиз,
які були зроблені на основі фотографій тіла загиблого.
Фізикотехнік, це Володимир Миколайович Єрмаков,
який досліджував череп В'ячеслава Чорновола,
прийшов і чисто фізичними явищами довів мені,
що це були чотири лінійних ушкодження на потиличній ділянці голови.
І вони були  нанесені послідовно.
Раз, два, три, чотири - одним і тим самим предметом.
Показав цей предмет і сказав, що він схожий на кастет.
Такий самий удар був у лобній ділянці водія Павлова.
Тоді були проведені й інші слідчі дії.
Зокрема фахівці Інституту судових експертиз у Кракові довели,
що машина Чорновола їхала зі швидкістю
не більше ста десяти кілометрів на годину,
а не сто вісімдесят, як наполягали експерти в перших звітах.
А в момент зіткнення КамАЗ, з яким зіткнулося авто Чорновола,
взагалі знаходився "в статичному положенні",
тобто не рухався. Слідча група на чолі з Голомшею
також виявила факт отруєння основного свідка події -
третього пасажира вантажівки, унаслідок чого той помер.
Та й загалом тоді, на початку двохтисячних,
команда Голомші фактично врятувала справу Чорновола від забуття і знищення,
спростувавши чисельні підроблені звіти перших слідчих.
Це підтверджує і син Чорновола Тарас, який від початку опікується
справою батька. Однак він не згоден з версією про вбивство кастетом
і вважає, що Голомша нині просто намагається
привернути до себе публічну увагу.
Я не знаю, чи були ці удари, про які говорить Голомша, кастетом,
чи не були. Вони були просто не потрібні.
Батько загинув в момент аварії це видно по його вигляду.
Удари наносились в потиличну частину, як каже Голомша,
у нього там ці сліди є, а в нього передня частина вся скальпована…
Це страшні кадри, мені важко про це говорити… Це страшні кадри.
Це видно, що ця людина загинула в момент аварії
і не мала ні найменшого шансу вижити в той момент.
Окрім того, додає Тарас Чорновіл, одразу після зіткнення прибула
машина з соратниками Чорновола, які їхали за ним.
Тож у злочинців не було часу на те, щоб дістати
з побитої машини тіло та пошкодити його.
Наступна машина з батьковими соратниками під'їхала за 30 секунд.
Дістатися, розмахнутися і вдарити ще п’ять разів
у тих умовах було просто фізично було неможливо,
тому я критично ставлюся до заяв пана Голомші,
мені здається, вони трохи змістили акценти.
Не через 30 секунд.
Вони розсталися і трохи затрималися.
Я думаю, що такі спеціалісти навчені,
як це робити, і робиться все дуже швидко,
і, звісно, все це контролюється вздовж траси.
Я не стверджую категорично,
я навів факти і кажу,
що ця версія має право на життя.
Результати всіх експертиз, за словами Голомші,
містяться в матеріалах справи Чорновола.
Нині це 120 томів по п'ятсот-шістсот сторінок.
Втім, на запити журналістів щодо доказів про "удари кастетом"
в Офісі генпрокурора відповіли, що таких даних в матеріалах справи немає.
Річ у тім, що вже роками кілограми паперів просто припадають пилом
у різних відомствах: то в київській, то в обласній прокуратурі.
Нині немає навіть слідчих, які були б ознайомлені і займалися б розслідуванням
справи Чорновола. Сам Голомша був відсторонений
від справи через тиск "колег" з прокуратури.
Ющенко ще був при владі,
та, на жаль, команда в прокуратурі
була зовсім не Ющенка, це була команда Януковича,
якщо чесно казати. У нас порядок такий:
якщо маєш процесуальні повноваження -
ти керуєш наглядом організації розслідування,
а коли у тебе забирають - ти забуваєш і більше не докладаєш ніяких зусиль.
Я звісно, що говорив, але я бачив байдужість
у розслідуванні і я зрозумів, що з тих пір все буде по-старому.
У родині загиблого теж усвідомлюють, що ані тиск громадськості,
ані зміна влади не в змозі подолати кругової поруки,
яка намертво засіла в стінах прокуратури та інших правоохоронних органів.
Наприклад, як звинуватити у вузькому колі судмедекспертів
колегу в тому, що той свого часу підробив свідчення?
Разом з тим, на думку Тараса Чорновола,
це єдиний спосіб зрушити справу з мертвого місця.
У справі є кілька кінців, де є дрібні виконавці,
які не напряму до справи причетні, але які зробили певні правопорушення
в ході розслідування справи. Просто треба брати цих людей
і видавати їм прямі звинувачення в серйозних злочинах - фальсифікації
в кримінальній справі про вбивство державного діяча.
Це до 10 років покарання може бути -
за незаконні дії, тиск на свідків…
Періодичне згадування нових чи то пак "забутих" старих деталей
обставин смерті Чорновола вчергове привертає увагу громадськості
не лише до смерті самого політика, але й до інших нерозкритих
резонансних вбивств в Україні. Це справа Григорія Гонгадзе,
і справа Павла Шеремета.
На думку політолога Володимира Фесенка, ті справи, до яких, ймовірно,
причетне вище керівництво країни, в Україні традиційно так і залишаться
не розкритими. І це лише підкреслює неспроможність української системи правосуддя.
Це одна із загадок української політичної історії.
Не єдина, таких ситуацій, коли є підозри,
що це політичне вбивство, а не просто трагічна загибель,
у нас ціла низка. Є політичні вбивства формально розкриті,
як, приміром, вбивство Вадима Гетьмана, але не знаємо, хто реальний замовник.
І тому таких загадкових ситуацій ціла низка.
І до них будуть повертатися часто, як у США
і досі є купа розслідувань і досліджень щодо вбивства Кеннеді.
У нас таких вбивств не менше десятки…
Пролити світло на загибель Чорновола можна лише за наявності
політичної волі і бажання Генпрокуратури створити спеціальну слідчу комісію,
яка доведе цю справу до кінця.
Утім, усі співрозмовники DW скептичні, що таке станеться.